[Music]
this is actually very real a lot of the
frustration that American soldiers
experience in Vietnam when they're on
patrol is they get hit but they cannot
see the enemy my name is Bill Allison
I'm a professor of history at Georgia
Southern University I've been a
battlefield tour guide in Vietnam and
also I've written several books on the
Vietnam War including one on the mili
Massacre I'm back to look at some more
Vietnam war movies and judge how real
they
[Music]
are so this is depicting the 101st
Airborne division's assault on Hill 937
in the asol valley in
1969 uh became known as Hamburger Hill
now the problem with this particular
Hill is it's pretty steep and because of
its steepness and that the paven guys
are well entrenched on the top and dug
in and also along the the edges of it on
the slopes it made it difficult for
aircraft to get in and hit it now the
Strategic value of the Hill itself it's
not the the the physical Hill it is the
fact that that art that that pavin
regiment is on it you know one of the
Strategies employed in the war by by MCV
military assistance command Vietnam was
uh body count attrition the more we kill
of them the better attrition was just
one of several strategic approaches we
employed pacification was
one actually this is very akin to a
World War I battle with entrenched
positions they've got machine guns set
up they've also of course because
they're already up there and dug in
they've got mortar sites pre pre-sighted
so as the as the Airborne guys are
coming up the hill they're you know
getting popped because they're in places
that have been
prided booby traps are synomous with
Vietnam the VC the Viet Kong especially
used them all across South Vietnam in
areas where they knew American or Arvin
soldiers might be patrolling uh one of
the most gruesome ones is this they dig
a hole and they put in two rotors with
puny stakes in it and as your as your
leg your foot goes down in it it rolls
down and it chews your calf up pretty
gruesome stuff the pavin got more
equipment so they can do more explosive
type things they can set up more you
know Claymore trip wire type things Etc
because they have more of that equipment
available to them so that's kind of why
in this case you know you've got more of
the explosive type uh stuff set up than
than the puny
staks the airborne troops did ultimately
take the hill after several frontal
assaults why keep doing it why keep at
it um in part because the paven guys
were up there and I think the blood
calculus the butcher bill was we are
doing equal if not more harm to them and
that that was worth the cost according
to the commanders this is fighting at
its griest 72 Americans were killed
after the battle was over looking around
they found over 600 you know pavin
bodies the controversy around this
battle was the
casualties plus days later the Army
abandoned the hill after it was taken
and that raised a lot of concern in the
United States about hey what are we
doing I like Hamburger Hill it's one of
my my favorite Vietnam films and so I'm
a little biased here but I would give
this probably eight or nine out of 10 I
think this is good
[Music]
stuff
okay challenge flag with that helicopter
coming in and staying stationary for so
long in that Valley in direct fire right
uh they would not have done that there
would have been covering you know Birds
helicopters around you know to to to
assist if needed because if you stay
still somebody with a I don't know a
rocket propell grenade or an RPG as they
call it is going to swack that
helicopter
and sure enough that's what happens you
know they're Viet Kong they're not
uniformed that's how you can tell havin
would always have the uniform women
serving with the Viet Kong yes
absolutely gender did not matter in this
war for for for the the Viet Kong or the
the pavin the North Vietnamese for them
this is an existential threat this is
they're fighting for their
survival one thing that's good here is
the VC withdraw because they must
realize that air support's going to be
called in to to support the guys on the
ground now and now you've got two sets
of wreckage to to to deal with so they
got to get the heck out of
there the whole premise of the film of
Le's movie here is to show the
experience of African-American soldiers
in Vietnam both as combatants but also
as Veterans of the war returning to
Vietnam it at least 300,000 if not more
African-Americans served in the War uh
in the early years of the conflict
especially the
6566 African-Americans were uh in combat
units and also casualties at a rate a
percentage much higher than their
percentage of the population in the
United States and this did not go
unnoticed uh people like Martin Luther
King and others began speaking out on
this and by 1968-69 this is actually
kind of leveled out I'd give it about a
five maybe a
[Music]
six this is actually very real ambushes
are very common the Viet Kong especially
use the ambush in part because they
don't want to be exposed in the open
because if they get caught out in the
open they're going to get hit with the
massive American Firepower what they do
is try to catch the Americans or the
Arvin soldiers out on patrol the VC
would have been concealed and in the
clip you don't see them that would not
be that unusual in fact a lot of the
frustration that American soldiers
experience in Vietnam when they're on
patrols out in the jungle or in the
mountains is they get hit but they
cannot see the enemy
theine you can see that the enemy has
them prided they've got their mortars
RPGs pre- ranged that's why the
Americans for scumps people have
pre-arranged lines for themselves to
fall back to what they're calling the
blue line and usually that's some sort
of physical structure it could be a
ridge it could be a tree line it could
be a canal a road anything like that all
that is spoton absolutely I just wish
Forest would put his helmet back on how
many times someone gets ricocheted off
the side of the head with their helmet
on and if you don't have that helmet on
uh that's all she
wrote in this particular scene they do
need to pull back they're Exposed on
this sort of Road embankment thing they
don't have a lot of cover I got an air
strike inbound right now they're going
to n the whole
area calling in an air strike this is
very common one of the big premises of
the the for the Americans in the Vietnam
War was to use the massive Firepower
that they had at their disposal you got
to remember this is a military that's
equipped and trained to fight the
Russians in the in in Western Europe
fighting in Southeast Asia they brought
some of those same IDE ideas there they
didn't do it all that way but certainly
Firepower was incredibly important the
problem is the VC are good at melting
away once contact is made they fire a
bunch of shots they melt away because
they've learned that the air strike or
the artillery strike is coming I got to
fight
[Music]
buba so now he's going back to Rescue
Bubba and this is actually based upon an
actual Medal of Honor citation Sam Davis
received the Medal of Honor for going
back to retrieve actually three wounded
comrades so if you rate this on a on a
tin scale I would say this one's
probably an eight this is pretty
good what you have here in this scene is
American PS uh being held by Viet Kong
the bamboo cages are actually for the VC
because that's what they've got to work
with uh you know they they don't have
steel bars laying
around the Americans were mistreated uh
it wasn't great but both the North
Vietnam and the Viet Kong in the South
the NLF the National Liberation Front
their leadership recognized the
propaganda value of American prisoners
of War so you don't want to mistreat
them too much in North Vietnam the
famous Hanoi Hilton that's where most of
the propaganda footage is filmed about
them being in church and doing a
Christmas tree and doing things like
that to show that they're being treated
well and whatnot um even though some of
them had been there for like six or
seven years by that point the South
Vietnamese they ran the P camps torture
the Vietnamese police National Police
especially in Saigon uh General Lan I
mean they tortured assassinated of
course we had The cia's Phoenix Program
we're doing a lot of bad things here and
and a lot of bad things are happening
under our watch for this these these
guys are rogue the leadership would not
be happy with this put it that
way this particular thing is a little
outside the realm the scene depicting
the VC making the PS play Russian
Roulette there is no evidence that that
occurred at all and obviously the way
they're depicting the Viet Kong there is
very brutal
barbaric uh you know incredibly racist
why well again we're talking the late
70s the war is still very raw we want to
still portray it is that they were a
dishonorable enemy so to rate this on on
reality uh pretty low I think I mean
it's it's got to be a three or four I
don't think it's in the realm of
possibility nighttime attack very common
especially during the Ted offensive the
attacks were at night on the 30th 31st
of January which is the big North
Vietnamese orchestrated attack across
all of North of South Vietnam uh they
hit almost every preventional Capital
the problem was in order to undertake
this VC units and pavin regiments have
to get out in the open they're exposed
again to what American Firepower and
they get swacked mercilessly the Viet
Kong are never the same again after
this so the positions there that's all
very realistic you would have had
pre-arranged defensive positions
trenches bunkers uh with machine guns
usually already set up as part of your
perimeter
defense so the pavin attack where they
should attack which is the main gate
that's the best way place to get in it
but the problem is it's also might be
the most heavily defended it's the gate
that the Marines have to use right so
they can't have it mined or that sort of
thing so that's actually in some ways a
weak spot to get in so was kind of a
weird I don't know dilemma there for for
the enemy but that's where they choose
to to attack
here very typical of the paven and the
VC Mass wave assaults support for the
war in the United States had been
falling in the fall of 1967 you have the
huge uh anti-war anti-draft protest in
in Washington DC that was a big signal
to the Johnson Administration that
support for the war was starting to
erode so he calls West Morland the
American Commander of military
assistance command Vietnam or MV as it's
called back over to give a bunch of
talks on the TV shows and Congress and
whatnot to show that no we're actually
making progress so support for the war
actually goes up public opinion pose
rebound a little bit right and then Ted
happens the American people are kind of
like well wait a minute you told us we
were winning that doesn't look like
winning this particular scene I like a
lot I I think it's pretty realistic it's
it the nighttime fighting The Assault on
the gate the the the the you know the
entrenched positions for the defense of
the perimeter Etc uh I don't I'd give
this a
[Music]
seven guarding Bridges very common you
often had us Arvin forces on either side
of a bridge over a river or a railroad
bridge to to protect it um unless you
wanted that bridge destroyed I'm not
sure you could be much more exposed than
being on a railroad bridge this is based
on a real incident uh a unit murdered a
young woman who they had kidnapped and
raped unfortunately in Vietnam as is in
the case in in pretty much all wars
soldiers do mistreat non-combatants
there are a few units that were
notorious for their treatment of
non-combatants and right on Q Here Comes
Your air power which I'm not sure those
explosions would have been that way now
there you see an American River Patrol
boat gets in the way and gets hit uh by
you know collateral damage there uh that
would have been pretty common for a
river Patrol boat we had River what we
call River reinforces so these Patrol
boats would have been going up and down
the major waterways I don't think it's
the best duty to have because you're out
there and you're exposed now these
things are armored plated they've got
some protection but you're really
exposed out there open to ambush from
either side of the river and things like
that so it was pretty dangerous Duty I I
got to I got to rate this one
probably a four because there's just so
much of it that's just not not
[Music]
right so we've got a woman Viet Kong
fighter using a tunnel all very good so
for the Viet Kong to have uh tunnels and
uh dugouts uh uh trap doors and things
very common when you go to coochie today
you can actually go down in some of the
tunnels the actual real tunnels and
there's a few places where they have the
trap
[Music]
doors now that's pretty crafty I don't
know if they actually had those little
holes they could slide a grenade through
or not push through their
rifle you know
man okay she was just running around
dodging gunfire and then she stops and
just stands
there it's like Get
Down what they're doing is they're
hiding the weapons so that when they do
come through they don't find anything on
them and they can just play innocent hey
we're just villagers here right um you
know wasn't us and you gota remember
when this was made in the late 70s in
Vietnam this is really promoting you
know still trying to you got you got to
show some Unity between north and south
and of course the VC were in the South
so you want them you kind of want to
resurrect their role in The War uh as
part of the national narrative for the P
the purpose of unification just the way
uh the smell of burning grass that film
that Vietnamese film made more recently
kind of does serves a similar purpose
Vietnam is a young country now I mean I
think 60s something per of the
population is under the age of 40 so
they don't have a li living memory of
the war but you want to keep that memory
alive somehow so how do you do this well
you do it through film I like this film
uh I I it's again when it was made and
and the the message it's trying to get
across it's purpose to promoting
unification by kind of resurrecting the
Viet Kong role in the war it's not
perfect but i' I'd give it a good six so
I have two favorite Vietnam films one is
from the early' 70s called go tell the
Spartans and it's early in the war it's
in the advisory phas and it's kind of
foreshadowing the problems that were
going to arise the other one I like a
lot is actually good morning Vietnam
thanks so much for watching please click
on the next video watch some
[Music]
more